again hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday
Monday morning podcast and just checking
could I stop doing that people I don't
have any new way of doing it can I just
say I'm just checking on you I'm gonna
do that for a while and every once in a
while I'll scream okay it'll make it
special
[Music]
anyways as you heard the the laughter in
the background we're welcoming the
lovely Mia at the Thursday afternoon
podcasts just before Friday and you
wanted to clear your name so to speak
for drugging the man you allegedly loved
I didn't drugged you
you took it voluntarily no I did not get
yes you taught you you taught why you
talked me into it I wasn't I didn't like
slip it into your [ __ ] cornflakes or
whatever okay I asked you if you wanted
and you were like alright you can get
[ __ ] you're just a liar
I'm not alike but what do you mean liar
how many times did you ask me to take it
before I actually took the [ __ ] I don't
remember seeing that's the magical
powers of the pot canal you're pulling a
Ronald Reagan right now memory magically
erases I don't remember probably a
couple times no I I don't want to do
that it's gonna get me all [ __ ] up and
you said no no no this is mellow yes I
did say oh this is coming back to you
now yeah yeah and then like that girls
it was mellow but you're kind of a
lightweight when it comes to we yeah I
guess so well yeah well Mia if you
didn't drink it all I wouldn't be like
hey have a couple of [ __ ] Yeager's
that's nothing tastes like syrup I
wouldn't do that to you I'd let you sip
on a beer or something is disgusting get
you like a wine cool well not for
nothing wine cooler as our wine coolers
I used to drink those James
pot cookies so don't really taste that
good do they they definitely tastes more
like weed than cookie yeah Jager
definitely tastes more like Jager than
licorice well I would just like to it is
gross - why do people is that what Jager
is that their base note different
talking like perfume terms know they
talk in a musical sense
No I gotta be honest with you I am I
don't even know what I don't even know
what it is it's disgusting it's like
like what is it considering of vomit I
never I never like liquor isn't it weird
you know I all I knew before it's just
it's one of those things that like when
I was first living in New York and would
go hang out at this awful bars on the
Upper East Side with a bunch of like
banker kids and young stock bearers and
frat boys that were like the Jager and
then inevitably they'd put on you know
living on a prayer and everyone was
saying it was the most horrifying
experience and I hate those kind of bars
and I hate that kind of vibe for that
reason and I feel like if I got talked
into doing a Jager shot which you know
I'm trying to go along have fun it would
just be the thing that put me over into
to vomitorium so Jager is not yes just
it's for people who don't know how to
drink well this is what it really is
though
but isn't it what the people in around
the world probably different drink it
differently than we do okay
Jagermeister is a german digestif so
this is like after you have like a big
meal he's said that that makes sense
yeah yeah made with 56 herbs and spices
at a strength of 35 percent alcohol by
volume whatever the flow whatever 35
percent I mean that's a lot no wonder
people mainline it like [ __ ] China
but a couple drug references in there
for you
what's white China's editor heroin I
think I think I don't know how are you
oh there you go it's a digestif so it's
not supposed to okay you're not supposed
to be doing what people are doing with
it I got it 35 percent alcohol to that
it makes a lot of sense I would just
also like to say in terms of the edible
there's a lot but ingested it is a lot
the edible that you ingested it was cut
into fours as is recommended it's not
like you ate the entire cookie so I want
people to understand that it wasn't like
he got the whole entire thing oh yeah
yeah but still I mean a lightweight like
me yeah yeah I was like [ __ ] tripping
you with 70 proof that's what Jager is
that's also insanely high Oh
70 proof I mean it's up there it's a
shot
well look let me just let me just uh
Mike Jack Daniels
yes let's say I'd like to know this
whole jack all my buddy your buddy Jack
Daniel my buddy I visit him the other
night
I only haven't only talked to him once
so I usually have a long conversation
that slowly dissolves into tears you
know what I mean Jack do you like
Jameson uh yeah I do it's all right
don't want your fancy yeah I want you
become a snob yeah
Jamie's like I got when I'm in the mood
yeah when I want to get [ __ ] hammered
Jameson you know if I want to have like
you know something nice and pretend I
actually I'm cultured I'll go with more
of a scotch or something like that but
that stuff that you have that's in that
like suitcase looking thing that coffin
yeah what is that that blue stuff is
that Johnny Walker Blue
yeah it's like a half gallon of Johnnie
Walker Blue there's a lot of it I don't
even sell that bottle when I went in and
bought it they had it in their liquor
store for 10 years and virzi was coming
out here so like I got to get this thing
yeah just laughing like the labels
different the thing it's the sickest
[ __ ] suitcase it's like it's so
pretty like it's leather and it's like
really what's that other one that's
really fancy when you're really
dedicated to damp damaging your liver
yeah I mean what's the one you have
that's really fancy that you haven't
even drank yet you've had it here for
like three years
Pappy Van Winkle's right did you break
that over when poverty was here no we
did but I drank I drank Pappy's with him
and what the hell were you Nashville so
it's here but you just haven't drank it
yeah I'm just waiting for that right
time when all everybody's over you know
to break it open and uh when would that
be
I don't know in other words you want a
shot Oh welcome try it like I want to
try that shot once the was at the Polo
Lounge and we had that that fancy [ __ ]
that you were dying again what you stunk
yeah you were like what was that louis
xiv yeah 13th or something like nine
zillion dollars in its stunk I've had
better
had better cognacs and that one comes at
that once that one's like totally like
that's like the boy band of cognac sits
which one because everybody who doesn't
know anything about it like me [ __ ]
sees it no the cognac there's a lot of
snobs and say Pappy's is for the price
is [ __ ] overrated
but it's still delicious though the way
to get all of those is just to buy the
shine if you go out and buy the bottle
you're an [ __ ] which I am you know I
mean they're completely overpriced but
it's fun when you have people come over
and you break out the bottle it's it's a
nice thing to do as a host but if you're
just gonna you should never buy a bottle
of that just for yourself and then just
sit there that's well I mean I guess
you're saving it sat there for like a
few years now you know you gotta break
it out you know the old me when I want
this how ignorant I was with and I'm
still don't know much about this [ __ ]
alright so save you [ __ ] kunti tweets
can you just dinner in a nice polite way
be like actually it's not 30% alcohol
how that [ __ ] cuz I know it's not 30%
alcohol it's like 30% of something bla
bla bla some eggheads we you know like
just as a human being you're supposed to
know everything right you know you're
into math and booze so you know the
answer to that you know a lovely
bartender or mixologists perhaps
listening who actually really knows and
is not gonna just like I don't want to
talk to a mixologist cause I don't like
that word that was that's right up there
with foodie right foodie which I've even
said and then after a while it's like
you know I I don't II I don't like that
the end fluey
foodie I'm a mixologist so what about
can bartender what about this do you
know how hard it is to be a bartender
though can you imagine switching places
with a bartender we're on a really busy
night it's like it looks I work on
restaurant industry yes were you a
bartender no but at one point I worked
the I worked a grill with one of those
tall chef hat and I was The busboy and I
washed dishes all at the same time it
was like a [ __ ] Carol Burnett sketch
the restaurant was going out of business
and initially I was just the busboy in a
dishwasher and then
had this guy working the grill and I
remember he quit I got fired he used to
just get hammered and dry he had a van
and used to just like restaurant pencil
the restaurant business [ __ ] nice
right this guy used to drive this van
and he came in one day and just had like
this [ __ ] like somebody just took a
belt and diagonally smacked him across
his forehead and what happened was he
was driving home to his parents house
and he pulled in he was so shit-faced to
either hit one of the cars of the tree
and when his head went to slam against
the windshield the visor was down a
little bit he like bent it though
there's one of those old-school like
metal ones yeah he bent it with his head
which was probably traveling a good 25
miles an hour when he hit it and so
anyways he got fired so then they had me
[Music]
yeah brochettes in that type of [ __ ] no
I think I became a dishwasher and a boss
watershed it was just like a
bacon-wrapped shrimp that we have
seasoned and so I would I would [ __ ]
set up the tables and the lunch rush
would come in which wasn't much of a
rush we were going out of business but I
would be sitting there cooking [ __ ]
trying to look suave like this was this
fancy [ __ ] place which it wasn't
because I was on the grill and I was
sort of eyeballing the lunch room
waiting for people to finish and as I
saw people finishing up I would sort of
casually duck down where they couldn't
see me like below the grill like I was
you know getting more food or something
and I would pop up and my apron would be
off I had the bow tie the whole busboy
thing on underneath the apron and I take
the hat off and I would run out there um
I would bust the table bring the dishes
back rinse them set them up and then I
would run back flip the [ __ ] burger
and then go back out and set the table
in case somebody else came out my god
and then I would go back yeah I ended up
burning a guy's hand the stress I
remember I made a burger I've told this
story before I made this [ __ ] burger
knows this kid Jason this Metallica fan
Jesus Christ clean she been out today
yeah I'd let her out this let her out
she doesn't [ __ ] she just pees I know
but she says go for a stroll I think
she's
farting cuz she's dead ass asleep yeah
but she doesn't care if she shits in the
house she doesn't have to clean it up
look at her though she's passed out whoa
oh yeah I put a bed right by them by the
window where the Sun comes in I have to
go soon so can we talk about this
jameson thing how much or whatever Jack
Daniels I promise everyone I'll finish
the story about burning the guy's hand
oh right sorry
what was it you were looking up how much
proof is a okay Jesus Christ come on man
I just asked a question
Oh Jack Daniels I just wrote a Jack
Daniels I should write proof that helps
then you go to the Wikipedia page can we
also talk about how your social media
game needs to step it up a little bit
it's 80 proof that seems like a lot too
well
Jamison is only 70 proof like what it is
about Jamison is it is your drinking
something he's supposed to sip something
that you're drinking that you [ __ ]
slamming and then they do a bunch of
them and it's really the ambien I would
think that the the sugar is just off the
[ __ ] yeah I remember the first time I
ever had Jameson was when we were in
when you did a show in Dublin our first
time in Ireland and you know I [ __ ]
love Ireland I love the people there
that know about it oh my god it was it
was the that was the first time because
you know I don't drink that was when
that guy gave you [ __ ] right yeah when
we were leaving who stand on a street
corner this Irish guy is on a bicycle
right if every European seems to be and
we got a little turned around trying to
find our hotel and I went up so my so
let me just ask this guy
and I said um excuse me sir do you know
where such-and-such is he just pauses
and he looks at me and he goes I do I
mean he's just still staring at me and I
look at you and I'm like um are you
gonna tell me I'm Weiss yeah I remember
you laughs you laughed won me over and
you're like well are you gonna tell me
he's like I might a moist
then he told me and it was all good he
gave me like a big smile and I was like
you [ __ ] Irish but you know you
Irishman you like you like black woman
so I feel like maybe that was part of it
too I think we like women in general I
feel like everybody likes black women
though
like it I feel like everybody likes me
let's just go off on a nice ego trip so
immediate like so high seeing me do
snapchat are you not into doing some oh
not at all no why
or Instagram you have an Instagram I'm
not into Twitter I'm not I like going on
Facebook I don't like any social you go
there can we talk about you so there
because she met you I have to do it or
else your career just dies and that's
where everybody's at so you got to be
there everybody's that snapchat now oh
yeah they are now you [ __ ] we'll be
back social media [ __ ] you just
running around the block yes it's fun
those [ __ ] Club kids they go to this
spot the spots the spot that everybody's
there and then they run across the
street to the new spot and it's the same
[ __ ] people just a different
background okay
isn't that the what it is do you
understand but how come you're not doing
Instagram you take pictures all the time
why don't you ever because they're nice
for people there for me oh I say
although there's a couple killer ones
from how great with the pictures from
Dean Del Rey's 50th birthday party
missing you [ __ ] I missed I missed it
I missed it that's true I'm sorry Dean
happy birthday Dean Del Rey he's in I
thought it was one of the sits I don't
know how you top this this [ __ ] guy
turns 50 years old he packs out the El
Rey theater his name's Dean del Rey so
it was del Rey at the El Rey right so he
goes out there
it was joe barton exposing wearing an
ac/dc [ __ ] wanted like a Hawaiian
shirt but it's an ac/dc shirt right he
brings up red bad red bad [ __ ] kills
it then it was D del Rey who [ __ ]
murdered one of the best sets I've ever
seen a map then Chris D'Elia then
Joe Rogan and then I had to follow all
those [ __ ] monsters right and then
after that he had a live band came out
and he sang the entire highway to hell
album he's such a great and [ __ ] Mia
when I tell you a [ __ ] crushed it
yeah like first of all the song that
they opened with was livewire now for
ac/dc maniacs I didn't even know this
they all went Bon Scott was still alive
their original singer they always opened
with livewire on all their live shows
and when he died in tribute to him they
retired the song and they didn't even
play it in concert for like [ __ ] 30
years until recently they started
playing it again so because he was
playing the highway to hell album which
was the last Bon Scott album he also has
the sickest [ __ ] tattoo on his side
of bon Scott's face which I know sounds
cheesy but if you see it it's [ __ ]
icon if it's good on finding believable
okay cuz otherwise it's on believin
people's like famous people spaces on
you unless that isn't fun oh it's unreal
amazing tattoo I remember when jim
Florentine was down the store I had to
show him like dude you got to see this
conformity it's obviously you know that
metal show I was like you got to see
this and he's got a Bon Scott tattoo and
I saw it in his face like yeah he's just
like next thing you know they were off
in a corner did talking about 80s metal
did they play this song when we went to
see ac/dc all those years ago I don't
remember if they play then so anyways so
here's a funny thing I go on last and
what's-his-face dingo so when you finish
your set just go like all right you guys
ready for some rock whatever right you
ready for some rock and then [ __ ] so
right then the band was supposed to kick
in mm-hmm and Rudy Sarzo from [ __ ]
quiet right and Ozzy Osbourne was just
gonna do do do do do do they begin the
[ __ ] song I didn't realize that they
didn't know that that's what was gonna
happen
mm-hmm so nobody was on the stage and I
didn't know to turn around looks like
this and I said rock and roll I was like
you guys ready for some rock and roll
oh no I yeah I turn around there was
nobody there as I all rights coming up
with a few minutes consummate
professional longest walk ever and I get
off so anyways they start off with
[ __ ] live wire and delray kind of
sounds like Bon Scott and he's [ __ ]
murders it then they played the whole
highway to hell album mm-hmm
then they ended they brought out hang on
a second sorry I almost knocked my
computer of then they bring up Dave
Lombardo from I'm [ __ ] gonna blank
here what I'm trying to name his new
[ __ ] band
dead cross ok Slayer obviously he goes
out he plays let there be rock and then
they played they played Motorhead ace of
spades and [ __ ] deemed like channeled
Lemmy it was [ __ ] unbelievable can I
tell you like when you missed it I sat
in on two songs I put what is so
enjoyable about being with you amongst
other things but like with being with
somebody that's really great too when
you leave but no it's like being with
someone who's so different from you like
obviously we're an interracial couple
there's a bit of an age difference
between us you just kidding me with
Rights and left's here I know but the
thing is like I learned so much stuff
about things that I wouldn't normally
know like I like rock music and stuff
but like you know your dedication to it
and like your childhood or your like
being a teenager the stuff that really
moves you is like nothing I ever would
have considered before and people always
make fun of like hair metal and all
those bands that you like legitimately
loves and when you talk about the
musician ship and the like the trace of
guns was there from from a lay guns yeah
yeah like all that kind of stuff that
I've seen documentaries a baby or she's
like you oh the emotion hoser the
composure
f is for family music and from person
and from Velvet Revolver yes all that
kind of stuff like since I've been with
you I've seen Michael deed Michael Devon
from Whitesnake I've seen ac/dc we saw
Velvet Revolver
we saw Foo Fighters we've seen I'm sure
there's a crow they're vultures I'm
crooked vultures what's oh with the band
that Josh is in queen of the Stone Age
oh yeah Jesus Christ like all these rock
shows that I never would have seen if I
was not with you and I think that's
really [ __ ] cool cuz I already like
all different kinds I saw Erykah Badu
with the roots yep we saw Bruno and for
real ours I wouldn't have seen that yeah
I wouldn't I wouldn't even have gone
seen uh speaking of white music I want
to go see uh drink your big black cow
and get out of here
Oh Steely Dan yeah that's right I
wouldn't seen them and that was one of
the sickest [ __ ] live bands that show
she was so amazing at the Hollywood Bowl
and that's my dad my dad was into is
into Steely Dan so uh ya know we've got
to see some we got to see some live
music coming up this year that's one of
the things we like to do I've seen so
I've seen like seen like if the smaller
ones I saw rivals son that was somebody
that Dean Del Ray told me about yeah
[ __ ] love them they're great really
[ __ ] great I saw him in this
little-ass Club they got it being a
bigger place now because I've heard I
heard him on the radio recently did they
plug in some big show that they were
doing but like the lead singers just got
a [ __ ] voice it's ridiculous and their
drum is insane who was the guy when you
did that Rhonda's kiss charity that mark
McGrath hosted great guy by the way so
they ever had a pickle back was with
Mark McGrath elosha a shot of Jameson
and a pickle back disgusting I'll never
do it again but he swears by it but okay
so it was a pointed at somebody random
person in the crowd he goes because what
you say sir sing a number one song that
you wrote in 1997 absolutely and then
he's saying that I just wanna fly
everybody in there was singing like the
into all the lyrics of it
but he very funny self-deprecating gun
yeah Navarro was there Juliette Lewis
Kesha but there were other deaf McKagan
was there obviously from Guns N'Roses
and then who else was there there was
some other Gilby Clarke
I don't know who that is he was one of
the guitarists and Guns and Roses the
second generation of conservation was
there Billy Idol's showed up at the end
Stevens
Billy Idol's Eve Stevens Steve Stevens
yeah
no Josh Freese on drums by the way who
you don't know him but you know him cuz
he's played on far for everything from
like Devo to Nine Inch Nails okay yeah
probably play with menudo at some point
you know is just some sort of [ __ ]
studio thing with them like [ __ ] I'll
make it sound good he's like one of
those guys you could just no matter what
it is yeah he's played with [ __ ]
everybody alright I gotta get going I'm
going to the gym now and right now and
then yoga tonight but I've been I'm
eidetic I'm saying it on the podcast now
I said on my snapchat I'm gonna say it
I'm an aperture on the podcast
I love snapchat I'm gonna do yoga every
day this month 29 days some kind of
cheating but why you kind of cheating
welcome so many people like 30 31 days
so I feel like I'm kind of cheating but
you know it's it's Black History Month
so I mean I'm just saying years ago I
wouldn't have been allowed to go into
you know you weren't alone that wasn't
allowed so I got a do and go back once
were that far enough you weren't allowed
to even read the word yoga exactly so no
I have to say this is by far and away
the whitest [ __ ] I've ever done is to do
yoga every day and talk about rock music
yeah yeah today is it stopping it that's
okay I love it I love you I feel like
ethnic today like I'll order a burrito
or something to try to balance it off I
don't know I guess it is I guess is
there's so much that what do you eat how
is that not ethnic food I guess a but
you know what makes something at me oh
the reason why I'm saying that you surf
with that you just said something [ __ ]
up tone Jesus Christ any time you
[ __ ] say anything I just said I'm
gonna get a burrito is a goddamn joke a
little
could say that under election told me
that there's so much Mexican food that
they don't really eat in Mexico that
they've just sort of developed for us
gringos although I don't think I'm a
gringo yeah the same way that if we
[ __ ] if we move down there we'd
[ __ ] we'd lighten up the steak or
something it's just the way it goes
all right burrito we'd have to adjust us
[ __ ] you would have to throw more spice
into the cornflakes today they wouldn't
buy our blanched [ __ ] down there are
European under seasoned food land and
cereal is cornflakes yeah but you know
what this saline cornflake this so is
the points this you're like okay and
like 30 minutes later you're hungry all
right I got a question for you name a
cereal with a point oatmeal it's not a
cereal it is the hot cereal no it isn't
yeah it's considered a cereal only what
isn't look it up what do you want to bet
I don't know it's a porridge is I like
that there's enough people I like mini
wheats is oatmeal healthy let me see if
I'm anybody else was dumb enough is
oatmeal a car but grain is starch a
whole grain complex carb calc align a
good source of fiber acidic Harper a
cereal way down the bottom so someone
did have this question do you consider
oatmeal is cereal is oatmeal and cereal
the same thing
Wikipedia breakfast cereal health
benefits breakfast cereal I guess it is
is oatmeal cereal
what is oatmeal alright there's a lot of
people with a lot of questions here I
don't have time to go through all of
this if the gross cereal and alcohol
that's how that's how very low meal can
be eaten raw with milk like a cereal
okay or heated and eaten as porridge
okay
okay I never said it couldn't be
considered porridge I just said you
never did say it couldn't be okay all
right well can I get at my points for
knowing the word porridge is that a word
that people have never heard of is that
something that's new do you think or
you've known me for 12 years in the Bing
SHANY
yes when was the last time you ever
heard me use the word porridge I don't
think I've ever heard
oh my god twelve years our anniversary
is coming up our twelve year he is stay
focused no I'm like you now I'm a DD I
still remember the burn in the hand
story oh good go back to it because I'm
leaving uh no I've never but um you know
you're going to yoga in a Hollywood way
arts well our 12 year anniversary is
this month how exciting is that
you don't look very excited no cuz I
just realized you're going to yoga for
Hollywood purposes what do you mean for
Hollywood I'm going here not me purposes
it's like when I went to go then I went
to a [ __ ] boxing gym and they started
calling me billary swank because I knew
I was never again I was never getting in
the ring you were going to that boxing
gym a lot though I was going to
Gleason's Gym yeah yeah yeah what
happened to that well we moved out here
so the commute got a little difficult my
trainer my trainer does boxing you trans
guys all the time yeah yes young guys
young fellas who still got that it oh
come on you can still do it you still do
pull-ups out here and you know skip rope
but I'm not going down some stinky ass
[ __ ] gym but it pretended like I'm
gonna get in the ring I'm not dumb
enough for disease and I'm slow as [ __ ]
so yoga purposes for Hollywood cuz I'm
not trying to be like a yoga instructor
or some kind of what are you saying I
think you're going there to somebody in
there like has a screenwriting class and
you want to get like a discount Jesus no
Jesus no not at all all right well I'm
gonna go all right do they give you like
a yoga name when you go there no they do
not
okay they call me by my actual name and
then they remember my name and they're
like thanks Nia for coming and good job
today
do they come very nice
nini namaste yo oh I like it though
do you I thought you're gonna laugh like
no stay all right I thought I was cute
no I'm gonna stay here no I'm gonna stay
here you going to yoga now imma stay
here Jesus bye later see you later I'm
gonna take [ __ ] stinky butt outside
in a minute then I'm throwing her right
in the [ __ ] tub yeah anyways let me
read some advertising and then the
burhan story and then we're gonna call
it a [ __ ] day here a [ __ ] day
oh all right where the [ __ ] am i oh head
space man new advertiser head space man
don't harsh the mellow please talk about
your experience with the product I don't
even know what it is use the following
introduction to accompany your anecdote
hey everybody I don't know what the [ __ ]
this is let's be honest most of your
problems start with your mind man fear
anger stress anxiety depression
sleeplessness this is gonna be one of
these products that like if you have
suicidal thoughts consult your doctor
what am i peddling here they begin in
your head but they can wreck your life
please include all of the following
points during your read well if you send
it to me I'm gonna read it alright but
it doesn't have to be that way you can
make a major difference in just 10
minutes a day the change comes through a
through guided meditation with the new
headspace app oh I like this okay this
is some hippy [ __ ] my apologies to
everybody at headspace mad headspace is
a mess meditation made simple you know
something I gotta be honest with you I
would actually download this I used to
meditate to the second side of Jane's
addiction's ritual however the [ __ ] you
say the rest of it I headspace is
meditation made simple it's guided
meditation that you listen to whenever
you want wherever you want right on your
phone computer or tablet meditation is
rooted in thousands of years of
tradition with thousands of scientific
studies that show its positive effects
like improving focus and
relationship harmony whatever that means
and decreasing anxiety and stress
Jesus is there anybody in the world that
needs to meditate more than me join over
five million uses already getting some
headspace man for free right now
download the free headspace app and
begin there take ten program for ten
days of guided meditation at head
space.com slash / there's no man the
headspace man take ten program is 100%
free
way to experience the benefits of
meditation in your busy modern life so
how do you make money
I guess I'm so addicted to it after ten
I start paying for it train your mind
for a healthy less stressed life start
with free trial your free trial today at
headspace calm / / that's head space.com
slash bird that's headspace man calm /
birth there's no man trunk club alright
don't waste a second of the New Year on
a crowded mall with trunk club you can
make 2016 your most stylish year yet and
the best part is you won't have to do
any work yourself 2016 is gonna be a
game-changer for you you're gonna get
some top-shelf ass with the clothes
you're pulling out of this trunk yours
fresh start
start the year off on the right foot and
the right pants with the right jacket
over the right shirt trunk Club is here
to handle your wardrobe so you can focus
on what matters stick an F and the Wow
please include a shut up trunk club take
the hassle man out of shopping by
finding the best clothes for you and
your style you'll look like a million
bucks or at least a thousand and that's
about three hundred dollars better than
anybody else in the club and you'll
always have the perfect clothes for the
season at trunk club com / peruse simple
questions answer simple questions about
your style preferences and sizing and
you'll be assigned an expert stylist who
hasn't made a name for themselves yet
your stylist will hand pick clothes from
the best premium brands just to prove of
what you like and send back what you
don't like it just like that a trunk
arrives on your doorstep filled with
hand-picked clothes that are perfect for
you try not keep what you like and
easily return them easy to return what
you don't like in that prepaid trunk
trunk club is not a subscription service
you only pay for the
you keep from your trunk no hidden
charges just great clothes it's a brand
new year full of possibilities within
with trunk club you'll start the year
off looking great clothes pick just for
you get started today at trunk club
trunk club with style you for free plus
free shipping both ways you only pay for
the clothes that you keep you just
[ __ ] said this this is way too long
to take advantage of trunk club go to
trunk club compr trunk club comp size
bra trunk club calm / bar alright here
we go
a little what can I come in and plug
something really quickly yes I want to
plug can I kick it this Saturday at
nerdmelt at meltdown comics 9 o'clock
you guys have seen me Instagram and
Facebook and tweet all about it but I'd
love for you guys to come out who is
some of the whole nine o'clock well we
normally have tone Bell al Jackson and
Joey roses DeRosa Joe DeRosa Joe DeRosa
that is not an idle sensation from the
Opie and Anthony programs right Oh Joey
roses but this Saturday we just got tone
and two special guests so special I
should come and check it out can I kick
it 9:00 p.m. meltdown comics it was I
supposed to yell yes you can can I kick
it yes you can thank you even I know
that one is that De La Soul is that
tribe called question oh it's try
calling whenever I know what those
groups sound the same to me that's how
white I am I know it just goes oh all
right well you tell me when you can tell
the difference between [ __ ] white
snake and white lion and great white
yeah I can't
great white and great in a lion head
whatever the [ __ ] I just said white lion
white lion had the guy who sounded like
Eddie Van Halen great white had the guy
with the raspy voice and Whitesnake is
[ __ ] Whitesnake okay you don't know
them in the data here either
she's laughing at me right oh look who's
here but me undies me undies take them
off in a stall boo doot doot doot me
undies me undies try them on a [ __ ]
towel tryin to make a runs with that I
don't know why you taking them off in a
truck stop maybe you want to get banged
in the ass the truck will appreciate how
dry your undercarriages as you're
reading all the [ __ ] graffiti that's
gross
all right me undies everybody this year
don't be predictable and show up at your
Valentine's Day date dinner with some
last-minute box of chocolates or a
bouquet of roses Oh shots fired shots
fired by me on bees oh I'll tell you
right now I am I'm waiting for their
enhance for speaking of rap music I
think that they need an answer at just
like this is like when that guy said the
bridge was over and the other guy said
no it isn't right
this is [ __ ] cherries berries and
[ __ ] flowers calm wow they're saying
that the flowers are gonna die the
Rozsival die in a week anyways
I like me undies man I like this 2016
they got a little bit of an attitude
give the gift everyone is talking about
show you special someone just how much
you care with a present you'll both love
a gift that looks great it feels great
something that says you deserve the best
treat yourself and your boo to a
matching pair of me undies the world's
most comfortable underwear you know it's
hilarious I thought you were just gonna
get them for yourself and be like to
your Valentine a treat yourself do a
nice set of dry balls with a swing and
dick happy Valentine's Day I think me
indeed should send us a pair of matching
undies for Valentine's Day
I don't think they should well I do me
undies all right I'm not gonna be able
to walk around wearing underwear that
matches yours because you know they're
gonna make it more effeminate you know
they're gonna have to lean your [ __ ]
way
I don't need any guy underwear with lace
on it anything oh there's a visual Jesus
that even disturbed me all right please
include all of the following points
during your read note motel is
pronounced modal motor Alf this
underwear is as comfy as it gets for
whatever [ __ ] keeps writing MOH - da
l you don't have any sort of where I'm
supposed to accent it so so I know it's
modal is it modal um modal this
underwear is this comfy as it gets me
undies are made of micro motor bowel
fabric meaning they're twice as soft as
cotton you know someday I'm gonna look
that up to see if they're just not
making that [ __ ] up and they just don't
feel great they look great to me undies
comms come you only the undies comes in
tons of cool prints and styles and new
designs come out every month
you won't want to miss February's
limited edition design from the
legendary artist Keith Haring the retro
design is inspired by love making it the
perfect Valentine's Day gift this is one
like the way black people wear [ __ ]
pants with the hang it down off their
their ass like this is the underwear for
them so they could be all you got them
limited edition joints st. les sorry
that was you know that was my idea of a
black guy but there's a white guy well
you haven't pulled up just out of your
[ __ ] navel you're just gonna sit
there sad in a club knowing that
nobody's knows that you have on this
limited edition underwear and I think
that that's why black people's music is
more uplifting than white people that's
why we have like the Cure and all that
sad stuff is because nobody knows that
we're wearing limited edition underwear
but black people are getting their props
right oh damn in them jewel joints right
I remember them from [ __ ] 2014 all
right grab yourself a pair and celebrate
the holiday sporting matching underwear
with your sweetheart and me undies says
this is just too [ __ ] long you know
what they are you know where to get em
go to me undies comm slash Burundi's com
/ burger for free shipping at 20% off
your first order of the world's most
comfortable underwear and lastly well
certainly not lazily sip
as a business owner your company is only
as good as the people you hire posting
jobs in one place is not enough to find
quality candidates short staffing leads
little time to post a dozens of job
sites so what can you do well you can go
to zip recruiter
you can post a 100 plus job sites with
one click be instantly matched to
candidates from over 6 million resumes
plus watch brand new candidates roll in
two zip recruiters easy-to-use interface
within 24 hours
zip recruiter has been used by over
400,000 businesses today you can try zip
recruiter for a free go to zip recruit
comm / birth at zip recruit at com / /
one more time hey zip recruiter dot-com
/ / see they know how long to write it
at these other guys with their [ __ ]
stories that make me go into a soliloquy
there oh by the way so as I was stating
I've told this story before but I
already started if you're new to the
podcast I'll tell you to see anyways I'm
working the sable cafe in Cary North
Carolina its 1987 going into 88 all
right I probably just got done seeing
Tesla opening up for it was either
ariseth on the permanent vacation tour
or it was Def Leppard on the hysteria
tour remember Joe Elliott wore those
acid watch rip pants the entire tour and
through all of the videos you know he
went Jim Morrison with Jim Morrison were
the same leather pants he wore the same
acid washed ripped [ __ ] jeans you
know and I'll tell you this right now
the man knows how to pack all right
plowing ahead by the way I always heard
jim Florentine really knows how to pack
drop it his name twice in this podcast I
always heard he's one of those guys goes
away for three weeks and he'll show up
with like a [ __ ] a knapsack and like
a cheese sandwich in a brown paper bag
and he's just [ __ ] good I'd like to
be more like that there I can admit that
I'm old enough now to say I'd like to be
more like jim Florentine
anyway so I'm working the sable cafe so
how it works is I'm glassed-in right and
right behind me is that little window
and behind the window is the kitchen
right and there's the line so this order
comes in they're like hey you know this
guy Jason's like burger right so my god
what private coming up you know so I'm
supposed to look at the order and if
there's a lot of [ __ ] on the line you
know if they got a basically a bunch of
entrees to make I hold off on the burger
so we could time it all out so it's
already I wasn't thinking because I'm
bussing tables and washing dishes while
not washing my hand total health code
violation right I shouldn't have said
that now that I said the name of the
restaurant but it's all gone anyways so
I just start making this burger so you
know I'm cuz I'm watching the table like
I got to finish this burger because I
got to go bust that [ __ ] table and
throw some dishes into the [ __ ]
dishwasher by the way I also mopped the
whole [ __ ] oyster bar and clean out
both bathrooms before I [ __ ] start
brutal right and so I just start making
the burger I put it on a plate and I'm
like Jason burger up and he turns around
looks at me he's got his heavy-metal
hair shoved up into his chef's hat and
he was one of those guys that grew a
mustache before he could grow one and he
just looks at me like oh I'm sorry go so
just [ __ ] put it on the grill to put
it to the side of the grill so I grabbed
it with tongs it was a glass plate and I
just set it on the on basically on the
grill but underneath the burner that was
off you know but just basically you know
it's a mesquite grill so you know it's
hot because the one the burner 2/3 over
is hot you know and it's all the same
piece of metal so it's basically hot but
not piping hot okay but it's still
[ __ ] pretty hot so I go on a bus a
[ __ ] table right and I wash some
dishes and I come in and all of a sudden
I got all these other orders for chicken
sandwiches and brochettes and I leave
the burger there I'm not even [ __ ]
thinking so Jason finally finishes the
[ __ ] entrees and he looks he goes he
just goes bar what's up with that burger
and I just grabbed it with the tongs and
he has both his hands out to receive
this thing and I just set it right down
in his hands and he just goes and
[ __ ] spun around
and like basically threw it down on the
unlike the would [ __ ] shelf that he
had there and and was immediately not in
the window so the whole [ __ ] like
dining room heard this muffled scream
and looked my just and then looked my
way and by the time they look I was just
standing there and I tried to keep a
straight face I [ __ ] I mean I didn't
really burn it bad he just made this
face before he yelled it was like his
brain was registering what the [ __ ] was
happening and with his [ __ ] hair
pushed up in his hat and that stupid
mustache that really wasn't a mustache
dude I [ __ ] ducked down and for like
seven straight minutes was like crying
laughing I was laughing so hard I
remember he wasn't even mad at me
because he was trying to be mad but I
was laughing so hard he started laughing
and you know then I had to run out go
bust all that stuff sit hey how about a
pad in the back for myself for actually
remembering to finish that story because
I know that uh that I didn't oh and by
the way I got a lot of backlash from my
given Australia [ __ ] for saying that you
know you only had one one attack and we
had three people look oh why don't you
look at the population there's only like
twenty three million people or some [ __ ]
and [ __ ] Australia there's like 400
million here well I will counter that
point with the fact that the top ten
[ __ ] most poisonous snakes like nine
of them all reside in [ __ ] Australia
you know like rock stars living in
Jamaica to avoid the [ __ ] taxes in
England right they're all [ __ ] in
Australia oh we got us a couple of
Rattlers over here okay
we're so dedicated to getting killed by
snakes we [ __ ] we had a guy died with
by a cobra last year they don't even
live here the thing was just visiting
bit him in a car they think it was
suicide anyways that's the podcast 45
[ __ ] minutes it's not bad for just
checking in on you it's Thursday
everybody all you got is one more day to
go and then it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] time at the [ __ ] party right
there's not what Joey DeRozan says all
right I'll talk to you later see you on
Monday
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
I need you guys to come up with a name
for this phenomenon you ever been
standing in a in an airport terminal and
there's some douche talking really loud
on his cell phone course you have we all
have right this is big dis giant -
there's a fat black dude from England so
he sounds like he's in you know lock
stock in Smoking Barrels whatever [ __ ]
it's called and he's a tub of [ __ ] which
is making me laugh because everybody in
Europe acts like they're [ __ ] smart
and in shape you know he looked like the
[ __ ] dude on you know you know what
he look like
you know that show the Cleveland Brown
show you know his son it's exactly what
he looked like
he didn't talk like him but he had the
[ __ ] round glasses the whole goddamn
thing that's what the [ __ ] he looked
like and he's talking and he's [ __ ]
he's he's American fat he's Chicago fat
all right but he's European so he still
has to wear those tight [ __ ] jeans I
don't know why I don't know what it is
about Europe and [ __ ] suffocating
your balls but Europeans just their
jeans cannot be [ __ ] tight they just
cannot be [ __ ] tight enough they have
to have to [ __ ] frame that package
that goddamn units look like [ __ ] Han
Solo's face when he gets frozen in that
little piece of [ __ ] carbon or
whatever the [ __ ] it was anyways
so he's running his stupid Yap yeah Mike
going over to Mel bone after that gonna
go back over the [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] right just talking talking talking
big stupid Chicago bear [ __ ] gut you
know you know when you get the creases
on the side you could stick mail in
there he's got those on the side right
offensive lineman fat you know he's got
great footwork though but look at his
[ __ ] belly and he's just running his
goddamn Yap you know so I walk away from
the guy but he's one of these guys who
takes a little stroll when he walks so
he keeps [ __ ] walking over into my
little area right sound my guy you know
Bill come off just [ __ ]
don't be this don't be [ __ ] screaming
and yelling just [ __ ] relax and what
is the name of this phenomenon they
start loading the [ __ ] plane I get on
the plane
here comes that [ __ ] douche right
still talking yeah might yeah yeah good
day mate yeah yeah well [ __ ] [ __ ]
I know good day mate some [ __ ]
Australia before I get [ __ ] from [ __ ]
people from England you all sound the
same to me right so he comes walking up
the aisle he's still running his [ __ ]
Yap and I'm just going on Jesus Christ
alright only off listen this guy for
another five four three until he goes by
and the [ __ ] in my room what
are the odds you know what are the
[ __ ] odds goddamn seventy [ __ ]
rows not only is he in my row he's
sitting right next to me and he stays on
the phone the whole [ __ ] time yeah
might yeah no no teddy bears watching
telly is this Stan right all [ __ ]
time why you swearing I'm not swearing
the whole [ __ ] time sit next to me
running his goddamn Yap with his fat
[ __ ] stomach and the crease on the
side and it's the only this is the only
the only props I will give this guy's is
you know he never seen ever said hello
we didn't speak the whole flight I loved
it I loved that he was as self-involved
his I am and the last thing I wanted to
hear I did last thing I want to do would
start talking to him cuz he already
annoyed the [ __ ] out of me and I know
from experience that if I'm gonna talk
to somebody from another country at some
point they're gonna [ __ ] on the United
States that's something that they like
to do while calling us the ignorant
Americans traveling around the world you
know all knees and elbows those
[ __ ] come over here and it's
just you can't talk to him for more than
[ __ ] five minutes before they say
[ __ ] on America I don't want to [ __ ]
understand it you know I would never do
that the only the only way I would do
that is if I was onstage in another
country just just for the [ __ ]
ridiculousness of it to start making fun
of their [ __ ] country but if I was
sitting on a plane I would just be
Tahlia you have a beautiful country blah
blah blah bye be a decent [ __ ] guy
I don't [ __ ] ah Jesus Christ the hell
was I just gonna try to remember
something in the middle of that the hell
was I talking about hang on a second let
me think about this oh yeah I remember
what it was did I tell this story like
[ __ ] four months ago I pulled my
big-ass truck into this small spot but
there was nobody on the other side of me
and I was fine right
when I came out somebody had pulled in
and it was really tight as far as like
on either side of my truck and then I
didn't have a lot of space to back out
so was his [ __ ] problem I keep trying
to back you know back out come back in
back out like into my way and so this
[ __ ] guy starts helping me out I
think he was from England and he's like
you know next time why don't you do the
unamerican thing and back in and I
[ __ ] I it's like you can't even help
me out of this spot with a [ __ ]
nitpicking you're [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
what I'll listen to it from Australia
but England the amount of [ __ ] that is
going on in the world still because of
those [ __ ] the fact that they actually
[ __ ] give you had the balls to give
United States [ __ ] the very least be
like hey welcome to the party welcome
you guys are slowly catching up to us
historically it's the biggest [ __ ]
oppressive douchebags on the planet you
want to come at me like that absolutely
but if you're gonna [ __ ] come at me
like you didn't do all this other
[ __ ] out there the [ __ ] caste
system in India and all that [ __ ]
crap the [ __ ] that happened to Rwanda
you know that's all I got two examples I
don't know anything else the Falkland
Islands Jesus the ignorant American
strikes again but you know what I'm
saying if I actually read I could
[ __ ] bury you guys in this argument
all right with you Jolly Rancher flag
whatever the [ __ ] you call it all right
thank God I don't have a gig coming up
in English after that little thing you
know
[Music]
dilemma bill what would you choose to
either have sex with any woman in the
world
Nia wouldn't mind I wouldn't care if she
gave a [ __ ] if I my choice of any
[ __ ] woman in the world just to do it
one time that wouldn't be worth it it
wouldn't be worth it to lose Nia but it
but my dick would override that wisdom
in the moment or to have access to the
truth about any government secret in
history what would you do all right well
how would I know any government secret
in history what would they know that I
knew it and then they'd start tracking
me down and then I'd have to be like
[ __ ] Jason Bourne for the rest of my
life never getting to sleep more than
five seconds between concussions all
right first of all if I could have sex
with any woman in the world who would it
be
let's see here well you got you Kate you
got you got your major groups I think
you have four major groups you have
famous you have celebrity women you have
like celebrities like movie stars then
you have you have rockstar chicks sports
chicks and then he got chicks from your
past you know some teacher you always
wanted to bang any woman in the world
you're gonna go back but she has to be
as hot as she was oh this is a dilemma
oh by the way the other day I was at a
comedy club in that that uh pink was
down was actually in the crowd and I
didn't go up or anybody walked by
[ __ ] absolutely like slump against
the wall beautiful absolutely [ __ ]
gorgeous I'm tell you something like
those [ __ ] like super famous people
like they don't even look real when they
walk by you they just like that genetics
like I don't know what happened
but I'm just like Jesus [ __ ] Christ
you know I mean I knew she was
good-looking right I've seen the videos
but everybody looks good in videos you
know and then half the time you see him
in [ __ ] real life I'll tell you this
right now if you ever see pink she does
not disappoint [ __ ] just write down
the checklist absolutely [ __ ]
gorgeous you know beautiful [ __ ]
dress that was sexy but not [ __ ]
she had the [ __ ] tattoos but not too
many of them
[ __ ] just absolutely [ __ ] gorgeous
I felt like I was in second grade you
know like when a beautiful girl walks by
you like a boob bill you don't even know
what to say um all right so let's get
back to it so if I could bang any woman
in the [ __ ] world well there's two
kinds of women there's the woman that
you [ __ ] is absolutely gorgeous and
makes you believe in an afterlife and
then there's the other girl you want to
bang just a shot of the [ __ ] up you know
what I mean like I bet there's a lot of
liberals out there that want to just
bang and culture just stick their dick
right in her [ __ ] mouth you know what
I mean but not like a totally malicious
way just really put one on her which
she's just [ __ ] losing it and you
know making noises in bed that she'd
even know she could make and you know
and make her be able to make those
noises even though she knows that you
voted for Obama you know there's that
kind of [ __ ] right and then there's
the other one where you just want to
[ __ ] you know run down the beach
hand-in-hand with some girl at least in
my world that's the only those are the
only two what would I do you know what I
would choose I would choose sex with any
woman in the world because that
government learning a government secret
I've actually done that on a certain
level and it just it's like being in
show business is when you're like would
it be cool to meet this person
and then you meet them and they're like
the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever or they
I don't know they're just like they just
do something that just it just blows
your whole [ __ ] image it's it's it's
the Wizard of Oz thing we you know what
you don't want to peek around the corner
you know what you don't want to peek
around the corner so what what I would
do is I would definitely I would I would
I would I would have sex with some and
and you know what I would have to be
somebody famous and then had a respect
for Nia I would have to be just to shut
him the [ __ ] up kind of woman although I
would love to run down the beach you
know why can't I have that why can't I
have happiness alright let's let's pick
one one of each
alright is there any girl I just wanted
who's a shut the [ __ ] up I would say
back in the day it would have been
Madonna but like she would just she was
like beyond annoys she was so [ __ ]
annoying she was like I would just want
to get out of the room you know what I
mean he always watches that Blonde
Ambition Tour and there's nothing more
nauseating than watching somebody who's
surrounded by yes men you know I mean
they just completely [ __ ] obnoxious
everything they say everyone's hanging
all over every word and they just
laughing at everything like that's you
know something that's one thing that I
have learned in this business is a major
red flag is somebody who has an
entourage
if you have an entourage like I don't
know I've already automatically judge
you as like alright this person is is
not something I'm going to want to
[ __ ] be around because the only way
I'm going to be able to exist is this I
assimilate into your entourage and when
you tell the joke that isn't funny I
can't be like I can't look at you like
that joke sucks I have to [ __ ] do
like what they're doing you know laugh
my ass off because you're paying for my
hotel room with the [ __ ] out of here
right that and and people who don't hang
out with Pierce
you know maybe they don't have an
entourage but everybody they hang out
with is [ __ ] like ten years behind
them in this business then that's
another that's another red flag because
then nobody's calling you out on your
[ __ ] right that's that's how I look at
it how did I get to that with this [ __ ]
you know what I'm gonna have to get back
to you on this one you know I'm a
[ __ ] 44 year old guy so I don't
really sit you know when I was younger I
had my I'll go back in the day my list
okay when I was a kid the Bionic Woman
all three Charlie's Angels Farrah I
wanted to bang I had lust for her Kate
Jackson I would marry and Jaclyn Smith
you know it's your fault for standing
between the two of them see you're going
down too but you know I didn't need
Jaclyn Smith cuz I already had the
brunette with with [ __ ] Kate Jackson
then who else who else in the eighties I
like what's her face the replacement for
Shelley Long was in the look who's
talking she came on at that horse smokey
horsey [ __ ] smoky voice whatever [ __ ]
he's supposed to say it's supposed to
sound way more sexier than that she had
nice [ __ ] curves got a little out of
control there after a while but you know
she still has nice hips I gotta tell you
uh who else you know it's weird Florence
Henderson when she had the worst mullet
haircut always turned me on more than
when she had that awful [ __ ] Oh
Marcia Marcia Brady when she [ __ ] had
the little short skirts on [ __ ] Janet
Jackson when she was on Diff'rent
Strokes who else I just see it goes on
for [ __ ] ever I just can't remember
anymore
he's never Cyndi Lauper I could tell you
that
she did seem like some spaz little
[ __ ] boy to me yeah and then that
[ __ ] the haircut that she had was she
[ __ ] had like a tic-tac-toe board on
the side of her head that just really
freaked me out
not that I was totally against that
haircut because I thought that chicken
bow-wow-wow I thought she was hot
[Music]
who the [ __ ] else but I like Lita Ford
oh my god that I like her I think I
might have somebody back then I can't
[ __ ] remember
[Music]
speaking of lonely I was just watching
television by myself speaking to it as
if it was another live human being and I
saw this commercial for this this this
new website called farmersonly.com this
is not a commercial people this is
actually an observation it was basically
showing uh you know some couple of
ranchers a couple of farm girls and they
just walk in the fields by themselves
you know playing with their face finger
playing with each other you know you do
that when you were a little kid you'd do
that little thing where you put your
thumb and index finger together on both
hands he didn't kind of do the little
almost like there's an invisible tiny
screw you know there's some poor woman
walking through like these uh a bunch of
corn you know and the cows are all
concerned to the point they're actually
speaking English to one that one another
you know about each of them going how
the hell they gonna meet each other
and then all of a sudden this Whelan
[ __ ] comes over the top and just starts
singing you'll never be lonely at
farmersonly.com so it's basically their
Facebook and you should go and look at
it on YouTube that's what you should do
you shouldn't work you know where do you
work what are you doing is it your dream
or somebody else's you just a cog in the
wheel you know are they really gonna
notice if you stop working if everybody
else is working why don't you just
[ __ ] you know Tour de France just
sort of draft behind a couple people's
today you know take a [ __ ] Monday off
so anyways check out this video and you
know what's the funniest thing about it
is the comments underneath it as the
amount of people who [ __ ] on you know
just immediately thinking out dumb
people are it's like these people grow
our [ __ ] food do you understand that
I'm sure they don't know where the rave
is you know well who the most popular
bands are or how to get from [ __ ]
Brooklyn over to Staten Island oh right
they don't how to do that [ __ ] they
don't know how to put on a [ __ ] shiny
shirt right go jump on the subway and go
down to Wall Street and make sure old
people eat dog food for the rest of
their [ __ ] lives yeah they don't how
to do that you know they gotta do that I
make that I make or
right or plan it so it grows they don't
make it God makes it and he makes that
fertile [ __ ] country you know it's
got to be really hard to catch herpes
out there you don't mean I mean it much
spread really [ __ ] slowly Jesus
Christ I mean even well you must [ __ ]
rub them at least two loads out by the
time you get to our house just sitting
there driving and driving [ __ ]
tornado man you pull over rub another
one out and by then you know what's
[ __ ] going over there for anyways
[ __ ] I got more teeth in her that's a
deal-breaker look now I'm making fun of
them at farmersonly.com that's gonna be
embarrassing you and your [ __ ]
neighbor are gonna join you be the only
ones on the site yeah I thought you
wanted to [ __ ] me it just was too long a
walk you know what I'm saying just bless
it's tornado season you never know
what's gonna happen I like how that
they're called the flyover States and no
reason to go there
yeah no reason to check it on the food
supply uh like you're gonna that'd be a
good thing to [ __ ] freak him out with
just show up with like a clipboard [ __ ]
you do and sit it boy well they actually
you know something they make themselves
kind of separatist because at the end of
is that even a word they actually say
this city folks don't understand what
don't we understand lowliness is that
what it is come to New York and be alone
with everybody you never heard that you
[ __ ] you know what [ __ ] them goddamn
farmers Jesus Christ what you don't have
your cousin's phone number so are you
sick of [ __ ] your sister so now you
got to get your own Facebook and see the
jokes are just too easy here people you
know
good pick
[Music]
you
[Applause]